hi there i've been active in what you
might call the field of artificial
intelligence for a while now of course
miss coffee bean knew everything about
the technology behind ai-based search
engines but i honestly didn't have any
deeper thoughts about what it meant to
actually implement a search engine ever
but i was approached by semi
technologies that made an open source
vector search engine called we v8
a vector what
yes exactly in this video we will
explain the general mechanism of modern
search engines it's especially important
to know if i'm ever going to make my
private custom search engine for my
super secret miss coffee bean data
starting from the data we will go
through and explain the most important
steps
transforming the database into a vector
database with a machine learning model
like fast text or transformers then
querying the database thanks to semi
technologies for sponsoring this
educational video miss coffee bean are
you ready to do the explaining bits okay
let's go
search engines are the algorithms
helping you search over large sets of
documents or other kinds of data and do
it fast these documents can be either
from the internet or the documents a
company or organization has on their
private servers when search engines
first appeared they were not the clever
ai-powered beasts of today we'll get to
those in a minute the first search
engines were relatively simple
implementations of full text based
search this is very similar to how we
look something up in the dictionary if
you searched for computer the algorithm
behind the search engine went and
matched strings to find occurrences of
the word computer on the internet or
text database there were clever tricks
for example to generalize from computers
to computer
word inflections got removed or simple
word distances were employed that you
also see in spell checkers like the
lievenstein metric that measures the
minimum number of single character edits
needed to change one word into the other
but you see there are many reasons to
let these search engines evolve into
something smarter what if with computer
i do not search for a pc or mac or a
compute cluster but what was originally
meant by the word computer a human
person usually a woman that used to do
computations before digital computers
were invented in this ambiguous case how
should the search algorithm know which
meaning of the word i intended taking
the most frequent meaning would make the
search engine insensitive to rarer use
cases of words even more think of what
happens if i search something that is
not even retrievable by simple string
matching like when i ask a question who
is the one who has the most money how
should the string matching algorithm
know that most money means the richest
or that the one refers to coffee beans
or even worse what if we try to do an
image search these two images might look
the same but if we look closer bit by
bit they are different because the same
content is encoded differently
so if we search for an image in a
database or on the internet we might
quickly fail if we just match strings we
need a search engine that is more than
just a dictionary lookup and is aware of
content and context so let's bring in
the heavy artillery of today's ai
powered search engines well ai is a
little of a buzzword here calling them
for what they really are modern search
engines are vector search engines over
vector databases vector databases are a
way of organizing the documents in the
database in meaningful vectors to be
able to search through them with queries
that are vectorized beforehand too
in contrast things in a dictionary are
organized alphabetically which makes
sense when searching by string matching
but vector databases allow us to
organize things even better based on the
context in which information finds
itself so we have a new system for
organizing our database or the index
internet based on the principle of
context words that occur in the same
context belong together we have here two
examples of how words that are different
live in the same context it becomes
clear that the computer which i turned
off is different from the computer as a
job description that miss coffeebean's
grandmother had of course one example is
often not representative so we'd look at
more and more examples like these and we
can set up a graph where computer is
close to pc and mac and the jobs are
close to computer 2 but pc and the jobs
should be farther away from each other
if we take in all the other words used
on all web pages or in our database we
can grow a big graph a dictionary was in
a sense one-dimensional as things follow
one another only alphabetically the
first character was our only feature
but now we organize our database entries
in this graph where things have more
than one feature one feature might be
describing how much of a job something
is the other feature might describe how
human something is from zero human to
very human with each feature or
dimension that we add the more
characteristics we can assign for a data
point therefore to what we have crammed
here into a two-dimensional
visualization we can actually give more
space where all the features possibly
hundreds each occupy a dimension in a
vector space to really flesh out the
complex contextual relationships hereby
each word becomes a vector encoding the
exact position of the word in this high
dimensional space to explain this on
even higher levels imagine you are going
to the supermarket in the classical
search engine case it's like the
supermarket was a long row of products
all organized after the first letter in
the alphabet
but the problem there is that if we go
and find the apples next to the apples
there are bongos and not other fruit
like pears or strawberries
modern vector databases are just giving
things more space for modeling
relationships better in each vector we
can store the position of each data
point in this vector space encoding
complex relationships in between so
after we encoded everything in a
meaningful vector we now have a vector
database and of course we do not have to
do this encoding of words into vectors
by hand and we also do not have to come
up with features or vectors entries
ourselves because there are already
available machine learning models for
this
proprietary search engines of course do
not let you choose the vectorizer but
customizable search engines like vav88
do give you the choice you could take
their custom one based on fast text
called the contextionary or the
transformers module or a resnet for
images or you could add your own machine
learning models to vectorize with but
for this explanation we will resort to
miss coffee beans favorite vectorization
method transformers that are
state-of-the-art at this they are
reading in lots of documents like your
whole database the whole wikipedia or
the whole internet not kidding after
they have read in all sentences in the
input data they corrupt their input by
deleting words and then they try to
reconstruct these words the words are
all represented by random vectors at
first so initially the output looks
random too
but example after example these
transformers start to learn something
about language by deleting
reconstructing words and updating their
vectors to be better many many times
until they start to encode patterns in
context dependent vectors these patterns
reflect which words occur together in
these many many sentences and which
context words have
a kind of self-organization occurs where
vectors in this vector space start to
cluster together based on how their
respective words behaved in the input
data
such a model has to be trained once and
we can now feed any kinds of text into
it without the need of retraining and
can encode our whole database
now with all the words indexed in our
database in vector form we can take in
our query pass it through the same model
to produce us vectors for the query too
and now we can compare the vectors if we
search for female computer the word for
computer in the query is also informed
by its context female
therefore we will retrieve the database
entries that also figure the word
computer in the same job context through
the same mechanism we can answer
questions too the cool thing is that
what we have explained here with text is
also possible with images videos speech
or other kinds of data too especially
because these vectorizing models the
transformers can handle all these kinds
of data to compute content and context
aware vectors for more about this watch
some of our videos on multimodality well
this is what happens on a high level in
ai-powered search engines yeah it's cool
especially because it does not need
human supervision that would be
impossible at these large scales but
admittedly it's less magical when one
really knows what happens right
we are not really telling you that the
google or bing or any other search
engines work exactly this way the
algorithms behind them are proprietary
and not disclosed but judging by their
capabilities and especially their
failure modes there is definitely a
vector database and the vector search
engine behind them the real lessons
about these modern vector search engines
we can know from open source projects
vv8 is such an open source vector search
engine you know open where one can
inspect the code open the documentation
this is important to have not only
because you know what's going in there
but also in the situation where you are
a company or an institution with
millions of documents and want to search
through them for example what if you're
a hospital with millions of clinical
data samples or a factory with product
data or a shop with lots of customer
data post all your data on the internet
to be searchable by google search of
course that's a no-go it's estimated
that more than 99 of data is not
publicly available so if you possess a
part of that data you would either have
to implement a search engine yourself or
take and contribute to the open source
work that was already done having
control about the search engine on your
data is important also concerning the
vectorizing model we talked about just
before that takes in data and transforms
it into vectors because that model is
good with types of data it has already
seen if it was trained on web pages it
is good at judging internet forum text
normal websites but what if you have
technical engineering terms or medical
data in your database in this case you
need to take this model and find unit on
that medical data meaning that you train
it further by showing it medical text it
takes it in and self trains by following
the same procedure as before it deletes
words and tries to reconstruct a text
based on the corrupted version only this
then lets it extract patterns on this
new domain of data like medical texts or
other domains we v8 even has a simpler
solution where for every undefined word
you can provide the definition of that
word and use this as a context and you
do not need to do any further training
so to recapitulate what we need for a
vector search engine first we need the
data then we need the machine learning
model like the transformer but doesn't
need to
which we use to vectorize the data so
our database is now a vector database
and we are ready to search through it
all we need is a query that we should
also vectorize with the same machine
learning model because we now want to
ask which vector in the database is
closest to our query but miss coffee
bean is not the best coder when it comes
to handling tons of data without running
out of memory and waiting for ages for
the search to complete searching through
a lot of data fast is not an easy thing
admittedly so here is where she wants to
rely on vv8 that has already figured it
out how to scale the vector search for
millions of vectors in milliseconds
okay miss coffee bean you are allowed to
check it out i mean why not it's open
source after all so now miss coffee bean
are you ready to find out the truth
we need to ask where can i get the best
coffee for my ai coffee break
ah around the globe exactly that's the
spirit we hope you liked our explanation
of modern search engines in general if
you're interested in a more technical
presentation about vd8 in particular
check out the video in the upper right
corner also linked in the description
below
you